I want to take up in volume 13, November the 4th 1921.
So this is the reason why God used fiat in creation.
Louisa said, "I was all identified with my sweet Jesus,
and as he came I flung myself into his arms, abandoning myself completely in him
as in my own center." Now notice that she's recognizing here the oneness that is
there in their union. So that's John 14 verses 20 to 21.
She said, "I felt an irresistible force to stay in his arms,
and my sweet Jesus told me, 'My daughter,
this is the creature searching for the bosom of her creator.'"
So Jesus is beginning to get her to understand
that what she is experiencing is the deepest cry
of the human race, that our need for God is greater than anything else.
It surpasses our need for survival and our need for reproduction, which are two
very great urgent needs in the human race.
This is the creature searching for the bosom of her creator in order to rest
in his arms. It is your duty to come into the
arms of your creator and rest in that bosom from which you came out.
So I want to give you Psalm 131 there. "My soul is like a weaned child on its
mother's lap." And this resting is what we do in
adoration. We rest in his arms and we allow him
to work in us and through us for others. In fact, Jesus said, "You must know
that many electric wires of communication and union pass between
the creature and the creator, and in adoration,
that's the perfect place for it to happen."
"Which render her almost inseparable from me."
Now I love the word "almost." I think that's very interesting
because in all Jesus' references to his blessed mother, he calls her
"my inseparable mother." He says, "We almost can get there."
Not quite. We don't have her prerogatives or her grace.
"Which render the soul almost inseparable from me provided
that she's not withdrawn from my will." You see, that's our problem
that we can withdraw from the divine will at any moment.
We don't have that extraordinary security that blessed mother had by being
conceived in the divine will and conceived in grace.
Because withdrawing is nothing other than snapping the wires of communication
and breaking the union. Well, now that's as plain as it could
possibly be. So if we withdraw from the divine will,
we just break the union. It's as simple as that.
It's like turning off the electricity. You don't have light anymore.
The life of the creator, which is more than electricity,
flows within the creature and she flows within me.
So he's giving us this image that we can now understand
and that is that the power running through the electric wires
and we have our houses wired up for this electric current.
And so when you turn on a switch, the power then is released
into whatever gadget your kettle or your washing machine or whatever
that you want this power to operate. So he's telling us that we have to be
fused in the divine will all the time, all the time, all the time
for that divine power to be able to flow in us and through us all the time.
In creating the human being, he said, I linked my wisdom
to her intelligence. He's going to make a number of points and this is the first
one. He's going to do the intellect and then speech and then breath and then
will and then eyes, for example. So we'll take them piece by piece.
So the first one is the intellect. So what did he do in creation
with our intellect? In creating her, I linked my wisdom
to her intelligence so that her intelligence might be nothing but a
reflection of mine. And if man reaches such great
extent with his science as to give of the incredible,
it's because the reflection of mine is reflection in his.
So to Corinthians 3, 18, we become like that which we worship.
So the Lord is saying that he connected the human intelligence
with his wisdom. Therefore, as we grow in closeness to God,
the thing that should be obvious in us is that we're seen
as wise and understanding people. That's very interesting. Now there's a key
for you. Wise and understanding people. Okay?
If you write that down, wise and understanding people
said that the world should see us as that. Even if they don't recognize
there's a connection between you and God that they would recognize
that you are wise and understanding. That's very important.
And of course, if you look at the seven gifts of the Holy Spirit,
wisdom and understanding come first. Wisdom, understanding, counsel, fortitude,
knowledge, piety and the fear of the Lord. That is Isaiah chapter 11,
chapter 11 and about verses 1, I always say verses 1 to 10
when it's the early verses of a chapter.
So if the human being has his eye animated by a light,
that means his enlightenment, it's nothing other than the reflection
of my eternal light being reflected in the eye.
So he's again looking at the wisdom and understanding
and talking about it in terms of the eye having light.
When we talk of human beings having light, we're talking about
enlightenment, interior enlightenment. So I want to give you Sam 36, verse 26.
It should be, is it 26? In your light, we see light. That could be verse 6
instead of 26. In your light, Lord, we see light.
In other words, God has to give us something
before we can actually operate. Our washing machines can't work
until you give it power. It's that simple.
There's nothing wrong with the washing machine. It's all fixed. It's all fitted
out. It can do certain things, but it does need electric power
to actually operate it. So we need the enlightenment of God.
Now, since volume one, we've been hearing Louisa saying continuously,
"God sent me a light, and therefore I understood."
This is what we're talking about here. So the second thing
that Jesus says is, "Among ourselves, the three divine persons,
we had no need to speak in order to understand one another,
and anybody who has had an out-of-the-body experience, including
Louisa, who has said this consistently. But even if you go
on YouTube and you'll hear people giving you
near-death experiences, as soon as they go on to the other side,
speech is not actually required. When we go into the spiritual dimension,
knowledge is communicated directly, intellect to intellect.
Speech is for us actually the people in exile, or as I say, the people on the
ground. So among the three divine persons, there's
no need to speak in order to understand one another.
However, in the creation, I wanted to use a word because on earth,
on the ground, as I say, we were going to need
the power of speech in order to be able to communicate.
And all creatures, at whatever level they are,
they actually communicate. And scientists nowadays are beginning
to study the way different creatures actually
communicate with each other. We all know about birdsong.
We know about the way that dolphins communicate, for example, whales
have a wonderful communication system as well.
They're able to communicate with each other thousands of miles apart.
So communication is the issue, but with
us human beings, we communicate. We're not good at communicating telepathically.
Some people are, but we communicate through the word
right from the very beginning of our lives. So Jesus said that from the very
beginning, I wanted to use a word. So I said, fiat
and things were made. So here you're talking about Genesis 1-2.
And as soon as God says I want, that's it. It comes into being.
For those of you who may have read the works of Maria Valtorta,
who has given us the wonderful insight into the gospels
and to the daily life of Jesus, this is brought out very clearly
in the miracles of Jesus, that when Jesus would decide
to heal a person, he would say, I want,
yes, I want that one too.
When he wanted to calm the storm, he said, I want it.
And the storm obeyed. When he wanted to walk on water,
the sea allowed it. The sea doesn't allow the rest of us
to walk on water, but it allowed its creator to walk on water.
So the I want of God is it. And so when we ask God,
you know, for his divine will in something,
we're actually saying, is this what you want?
But even in our daily communications with each other,
we also are trying to find out, is this what you want?
Is this what you ask me to do? And we get a clarification
from them. Is this what you want?
So the I want of God brought everything into being.
And the I want of God's Son brought all the healings
and resurrections and cleansings of lepers and everything else into being.
I want. So if he wants it, that's it.
Now we do know that he wants us in the divine will.
So at the moment we agree, and every moment we agree,
he will pour into us his grace in order to enable us
to do what he actually wants us to do.
And he tells us in all of these writings of Louisa,
how to operate in the divine will because he actually wants us to do that.
So he said, I wanted to use the word and the whole of the scriptures
is the explanation of that word.
In fact, when Moses received the Ten Commandments from God,
unfortunately, in the Western world, we call them the Ten Commandments.
And Hollywood has eternalized this
by a thundering voice saying, "Thou shalt not, thou shalt not."
And absolutely distorted the thing altogether.
The people of Israel understand the Ten Commandments as the Ten Words of God.
And a word is a revelation. A word is a message.
A word is a creative communication between God and the human race.
And those Ten Words that God communicated through Moses
gave the revelation to faulty human beings.
Many of them not obeying God's will.
It gave them the pattern for which human beings could live peacefully
with each other on the earth.
For example, if ten people are living in a neighborhood,
I mean ten households, and all of those households
are living those ten words, it means that everybody in that neighborhood
has their property secure, their relationship with their spouses secure,
their reputation is secure, their relationship with God is secure.
Everything is secure if those ten words are actually put into practice.
It's when society actually deteriorates and people have
pulled out from that commitment to those ten words
that you get murders and you get robberies and you get suicides and you
get all kinds of terrible aberrations going on.
Because they've gone outside of the pattern that the
maker of the universe said this is how it will work.
And yet each one of us when we have bought a machine, I'll go back to the
washing machine again, if you have bought a washing machine
you got a manufacturer's handbook going with it.
Explaining how the machine was made, how it was put together,
what it was meant to do, how to do it. And also you get the instruction that if
something goes wrong, this is how you troubleshoot.
And if the troubleshooting doesn't work, contact the manufacturer.
Well now that's the Bible in a nutshell.
It's telling us that the manufacturer of the universe,
the manufacturer of the human race has put these beings on the earth
for a particular purpose and they can do these things
and it will work within the revelation of the ten words.
If you go outside of the ten words you're going to need an awful lot of troubleshooting.
And when the troubleshooting doesn't work as it most of the time doesn't
there's only one thing to do and that is go back and have recourse to the maker.
Go back to the one who actually made these creatures
and that is how you will find out how to solve the problem.
So this word of the Lord is actually terribly important.
And of course in case I forget when Jesus became incarnate
the word that had been issued at the dawn of creation became flesh
and dwelt among us and so the word came to us in person.
And when we celebrate the Eucharist we first of all
the first half of the liturgy we celebrate the word
and the second half we celebrate himself.
The word and the sacrament are two sides of the one person.
So Jesus said in creation I that is God because Jesus is God
he's one of the three divine persons.
I wanted to use the word so I said fiat and all things were made.
And the scientists have now demonstrated.
I mean by the scientists I mean the astrophysicists have now demonstrated.
They've gone way beyond the big bang none of them believe the big bang anymore.
It was wonderful when I heard some professors saying
we no longer believe the big bang because you'd need a match
to create the big bang. Well now any six-year-old could have told them that but
they had to find out that the hard way because they're very intelligent people.
And now they have gone right back and they have gone back to
a point a single point which they call a singularity
and they say that the creation happened so fast
I mean the entire universe came into being so fast
that they had to make a new estimation of time
so that they could sort of say it took X number of seconds to do it.
But in the new time that they have developed they're talking about
trillions beyond trillions beyond trillions beyond trillions below one second.
Our minds cannot take on board what the scientists are actually saying
but we knew this from the Lord anyway.
It's taking them millennia to come to something they could have read about
in scripture.
And so that I want of God meant instant creation.
And the creation is still expanding and when we come into the divine will
the I want of God comes into you and your soul begins expanding expanding
and he creates new heavens and new stars new everything
inside of you and the mystery of creation and recreation
begins to work inside of us. That's the miracle that we're involved in.
That's the mystery that's the wonder.
To this fiat Jesus said I bound and gave the power
that creatures might have the word in order to understand one another.
So he gave us the word to understand one another.
Therefore human voices are also linked
to my first word which is fiat and therefore
the greatest word that we can give to him is fiat.
Fiat miki secondum verbum to him. Be it done onto me
according to your word. That's the greatest thing we can say to him.
And I think we need to see say fiat very very frequently
to give joy to the blessed Trinity that the human race is beginning to come back.
To this fiat I bound and gave the power that creatures might have the word
in order to understand one another. Therefore human voices are also linked
to my first word as though by an electric wire
and from it all other words to send.
And as I created man I breathed it on him with my breath.
That's Genesis 2-7. Infusing life into him.
That's an exact quotation of Genesis 2-7. But in this life
I infused in him. I placed my whole life
in this life. We're talking about living in the divine world.
I placed my whole life according to what human capacity
was able to contain. So he has given us his whole life.
But if my capacity is that of a thimble then
I am an absolute miniature of him. If my capacity is that of a jog
I am still a miniature of him but a bigger one.
If my capacity is that of a huge container
like one of these oil tanks then yes I'm a bigger image
but it's still a miniature of him because he's divine and human.
So each one of us is meant to be a miniature
of Jesus himself the word. One of the things I love
about St. Therese of Liz Hugh you often hear me talk about her
is that the pope who canonized her said that she was a miniature
of Christ. That's the greatest thing he could have said
and in fact once he said that nothing else was required.
So in this life I infused in him I placed my whole life
according to what the human capacity was able to contain.
But I placed everything in him. You may be a miniature but everything's there.
There's something about miniatures that's actually very attractive to us.
When we see enormous beauty in detail in a miniature
you just lost and wonder at the the artist that could do such a thing.
There was not a story when I say I made a mistake back there.
In the creation I breathed on him with my breath
infusing life into him and I said now in the divine will
but of course Adam was created in the divine will.
That's the bit I need to insert in there.
So I'm correct in saying that this is what he does in the divine will
but he actually created Adam and Eve in the divine will.
And that's why he placed everything in the human being.
And there was nothing of my own that I did not share with him.
So Adam and Eve had divine life,
divine union, divine love. It was absolutely amazing.
They had divine knowledge. Adam and Eve had knowledge of everything
they didn't have to learn. And look at the knowledge that Louisa has
in these writings of mystical union with God
and she has never learned either.
So even his breath is the reflection of my breath
with which I give him continuous life.
So the first thing was the intellect. The second thing was speech
and now it's the breath. And that breath has been given by God,
wanted by God. And his breath is a reflection of my breath
with which I give him continuous life. So with every breath
we should consciously breathe in the breath of God.
We're breathing it anyway but if you breathe it in consciously as the breath
of God you won't worry about COVID-19 or anything else.
While his breath is reflected in mine
that's Adam's breath was reflected in God.
And I feel it continuously within me. So the divine will
was operating in man.
So there's this wonderful communication going on.
See then how many relations or connections
or bonds there are between myself and the creature.
This is why I love her so much. When you say her
you mean the soul. Because I look at her as a birth from me
exclusively mine. Now I've got to give you a little
moment of duty.
A class of seven-year-old girls were asked
by a teacher who needed her head examined. Why did their parents love them?
They were given all kinds of reasons and then finally one little girl who
was obviously intending to be a philosopher in the future
said they love us because nobody else does.
And then it was up to the teacher to fill out
that little revelation that the child gave and that is
they love you because you're theirs. I love you because you are mine
and you find exactly the same thing in Isaiah
40 to 43. I love you. I have made you. I redeemed you.
You are mine. Okay. And it's this thing
that when a parent looks at a very small child
that they have brought into being everything inside of them goes out in
love to that creature because that little creature is a reflection of the
parent. I am you in another generation.
I am the incarnation of your love and that's what we are.
We are the incarnation of God's love.
And therefore it's this you are mine and the early books of the Bible
are quite strong in repeating over and over
about God's jealousy. Now God's jealousy is this exclusive love.
You are mine. You don't belong to anybody else.
And it's exactly the same with parents. This child is mine.
Other people would be told to mine their own business.
This is my child. I will take care of him.
I will do everything for this child and it's an affront to the parent
if anybody else wants to interfere. Well that's exactly how God feels about
us. And that's why you read those wonderful words
in Deuteronomy 32, 12, "The Lord alone was her guide"
which is true in a very real way here with Louisa.
And then he said we're coming to the next one now. We've done the intellect,
speech, breath and now we're coming to the the will.
And then how did I ennoble the will of man?
I ennobled it because I linked it with mine
giving it all my prerogatives. I made it free.
No other creature is free. We're the only free people. We're the only ones who
could say yes and no. If you plant a flower in your garden
it is going to grow and it's going to flower.
It has no freedom, not to.
But we are free. He said I made it free
just like mine. That's where we are so like God.
So that's Psalm 86 verse 4. I said you are God's
all of you sons of the Most High. And Jesus quoted that in John chapter 10.
And I also want to give you Psalm 8.
Yet you made us little less than a God with glory and honor your crown dust and
gave us power over the works of your hands and you put all things under our
feet. This is incredible. Okay. So he said how did I ennoble the
will of man? I linked I did it by linking it with mine.
So the will of man reaches its most noble position
when we bring the will back into full connection with the divine will
by our surrender to the divine will. I made it free he said just like mine
and if to the body I had given two little lights
limited and circumscribed which started from my eternal light over the eyes
at the human will I made all eyes. There's your interior sight your interior
understanding.
And with this interior gaze that we have we can look at a person
and know things about them without ever being told.
You can look at a person and know whether they're living a good life or a
bad life. You can look at them and know whether they are sick or well
whether they're happy or unhappy.
Whether they're in a time of stress or a time of peace.
Our eyes can read that and the more deeply we go into union with God
the more completely you can read another person.
To the point of actually telling that person something about themselves
that they've never told anybody else and that's very often the door
to opening that person up to God.
Yes that's usually called a word of wisdom or a word of knowledge.
He said I made the human will all eyes. Therefore
as many acts as the human will forms so many eyes
can it say it possesses. So each act of our will is extremely important.
It looks to the right it looks to the left it looks to the back it looks to the
front and that's why when you get a description
in the book of Ezekiel in chapter 1
you get a description of God the only one who ever
tried it except John in the book of Revelation.
He describes incredible angel-like creatures with eyes all over the place
and if someone tries to draw it it looks quite ugly to me.
But what they're actually saying is full of wisdom
full of understanding.
And as we grow in closeness to God we grow in fullness of wisdom and
understanding. And if the human life is not
animated my my will it can do nothing good.
Now that's John 15 5 without me you can do nothing.
In creating the human will I said to it you will be my sister upon the earth.
My will from heaven will animate yours on the earth.
We will be in continuous communication or
reflections is what my book says. And whatever I will do
you will do as well that's the echo.
I by nature and you by the grace of my continuous reflections.
I will follow you like a shadow. I will never leave you.
There's Sam 139. Where can I go from his spirit?
Where can I flee from your face? If I go to the heavens you are there.
If I go into the depths of the sea you are there. If I go into darkness your
darkness is not dark to you and the nicest as bright as the day.
In actual fact we can't leave him and he can't leave us.
So I will never leave you Joshua 1 5 where Jesus said that
they chosen people at the beginning of their life in the promised land. I will
never leave you or desert you. You have Matthew 28 28
where Jesus says I will be with you on all the days that are coming
even to the very end. There's also a text in John 14 I don't remember the
verse but that will help you to go looking.
Where Jesus says I will never leave you or desert you.
Never. So if we have a sense that there's a
gulf between us and God we have created it and what creates the
gulf is our rebellion, our going out of his divine will,
our sinfulness. That creates the gulf but he will never leave us.
And of course the the greatest communication
between God and us is the intellect to intellect
and people like Saint John of the Cross have told us that intellectual
visions are the highest level of communication
that we can have with God. Louisa had these other saints have them as well
and John of the Cross explained them very well.
So he continues my only purpose in creating man
was that he would do my will in everything.
That needs to be taken off the page and written up on your fridge.
The only reason why we were created was to do God's will.
When you read the Old Testament scriptures
from page three or should say chapter three of Genesis
right to the very end God is struggling with the human race
to try and get the human race or somebody in it
to do his will. If the chosen people had done God's will
they would have set up the kingdom of God on earth and everything would have
taken off from there. Fast forward if the early church had been perfect
then everything did in fact take off from there
but the world would have long since have been conquered
if the church had been at the level that she should have been at.
And sadly if the church wasn't in crisis
neither would the world be in crisis at this moment either.
So my only purpose in creating man was that he would do my will in everything
but with this I wanted to bring into existence
new births from myself. I wanted to make of him a
prodigious portent worthy of me and in everything
that he would be similar to me. Alas the human will was going to be the
first to set itself against me. Now we do know
that Satan was involved in seducing man and all the rest of it
but here we're looking at the enormity of the tragedy
that God wanted to give all the gifts through
the human will and it's the human will that actually rebels.
Take a look he said. All things are done between two
you have eyes but if you did not have external light
which illuminates you you could see nothing.
You have hands but if you did not have the necessary things with which to do your
works you could do nothing and so with all the rest.
Now this is how I want sanctity in the human being.
Between her and me it is between the two of us.
This is a he and I mystery and we have to understand this
each one of us even though we're all trying to live in the divine will
we're all trying to grow and closeness to him at the same time what is happening
in each one of us is unique is unrepeatable
and is totally a he and I thing. Make sure you are not copying
somebody else. Make sure you give your own
inward authentic responses to God. Make sure
you're saying your own prayers and not just repeating other people's prayers.
Make sure because this is a he and I mystery.
This is how I want the sanctity of the human being
between the soul and me it's going to be between the two of us.
I on one side she on the other. He says that I will be giving of my own life and
communicating my sanctity to her as her faithful companion
then our job is to receive it. So she receives it as my faithful companion
and my inseparable companion. Now inseparable means that we are living
at the level of union with God. In this way she would be the eye that sees
and I would be the sun that gives her light.
She would be the mouth that speaks and I would be the word.
I want to give you a mark 315 there. She would be the hands and I would be the
one who administers the work to let her operate.
She would be the foot and I would be the step.
She would be the heart and I would be the heartbeat.
But who forms this sanctity? This sanctity is formed by my will alone.
This is divine will sanctity. Okay?
This is divine will sanctity. He does it. So I am the eye. He is the light.
I am the mouth. He is the word. I am the hands. He is the administrator of the
work. I am the foot. He is the step. I am the heart
and he is my very heartbeat. He is my breath. He is my life. He's everything.
My will alone is that which maintains the purpose of creation in order.
The sanctity of my will is that which maintains perfect balance
between the creature and the creator.
These are the true images which will come out of me.
Now that is Romans 829 but I also want to give you Romans 819.
That same Paul says that the whole of creation
is crying out for the true sons of God to show themselves.
Okay? And these true sons of God have to be true images of God.
We've got to be like him because the restoration can't happen
unless man comes back into the original order.
And so Jesus is describing very beautifully there
how we are to come back into the original order.
So November the 8th 1921 to live in the divine will means to multiply the life
of Jesus. As I was in my usual state my beloved
Jesus made himself seen while taking a light from my interior
and carrying it away. Now notice the light is inside of her.
That's Matthew 514. You are the light of the world and this light
has got to be put on a pedestal so that everyone will see it
and give glory to the Father in heaven. So it goes on from 14 to about 17.
So this light is inside of her and we've shouted Jesus what are you doing?
Do you want to leave me in the dark? And he all sweetness said my daughter don't
worry I'm taking your little light with me
but I leave you mine. Oh I wouldn't have a problem with that.
You can take all the light that I have away and give me yours that would be just
absolutely fine. This little light of yours is nothing
other than your will he said which having placed itself
in front of mine to Corinthians 3 18 has received the reflection
of my will to Corinthians 3 18 says you become like
that which you worship. Therefore it became a light
because God is light and so that light is reflected on us.
I also should give you the book of Exodus and I think
it's chapter 34 and I don't remember the verses where Moses came down from the
mountain having been on the mountain for 40 days and 40 nights
and his face was glowing. His face was glowing
to such an extent I would imagine the light was not just in his face in his
whole person that even Aaron was afraid and in order to get the people to come
close to him he had to cover his face with a cloth
because they couldn't cope with the light that was coming from his person.
So we go into the light of God and his light is reflected on us
on us and in us. So because this light was taken from
Louise's interior so it was in her the enlightenment is given to us
inside.
So Jesus said this little light of yours is nothing other than your will
which having placed itself in front of mine has received the
reflection of my will therefore it became a light.
I'm taking it in order to let it go round.
I will take it up to heaven as the most rare
and the most beautiful thing which the human will
that has received the reflection of the divine will.
Why would he take it up to heaven? All the saints and all the angels need to
know that the human race is beginning to come home.
The prodigal son is beginning to return.
And of course when the prodigal son begins the journey home
then the feasting starts and the feasting starts with the father.
That's why Jesus takes this little light out of Louise's heart
brings it to heaven to show the father. "I will let it wander among the divine
persons," he said. That's the most holy trinity.
So that they may receive the homage and the adoration of their own reflections.
That's your two Corinthians 3-18. The only ones
that are actually worthy of them because they're in the divine will.
And then I will show it to all the saints so that they too may receive the glory
of the reflections of the divine will in the human will.
So that is what happens. Put a little marker there.
And it is the reflection of the divine will in the human will
which means that the human race is returning.
That the human will is coming back into subjection
to the divine will so that God can reign on the earth.
And this is such a miracle. It's such a wonder that all heaven rejoices.
And then he said, "I'll make it flow throughout all the earth so that
all may take part in such a great good," because this is only
a beginning. And gradually this needs to flow out into the whole earth
and become a great river and then a great ocean
and conquer the earth so that God can reign on the earth.
Immediately Louisa said, "My Lord forgive me. I thought that you
wanted to leave me in the dark. This is why I said what are you doing.
But when it's about my will, feel free to take it whenever you want."
So while Jesus was carrying this little light in his hands, I cannot say what
happened. She said, "I lack the words to express myself."
Because something that happens on a supernatural level is
extremely difficult to express in human words.
I just remember that he placed the little light in front of his person
and the little light received all of his reflections
in such a way as to form another Jesus.
Because in this divine will spirituality,
when the human will comes back into the divine,
as it does, it is made into another Jesus.
And what we will have on the earth is that the mystical body of Christ
will incarnate him fully. He will live on the earth.
That's how he's returning. It's a great mystery
and it's the most marvelous thing that we're alive for this.
And every time my will repeated its acts,
so many Jesuses were multiplied.
So all the acts become divine lives which are spread out into heaven
and into the earth. So Jesus said, "Now do you see what it means
to live in my will? It is to multiply my life
as many times as one wants and to repeat all the good that my life
contains." So you need a VIP on that little
verse. "Living in the divine will means multiplying
Jesus's life for as many times as one wants,
because you'll do that every time you do an act,
and to repeat all the good which my life contains.
And the earth is in such dire straits at the moment,
it needs this as its healing and resurrection."
Afterwards, Louisa was saying to Jesus, "My life,
I enter into your will to be able to extend myself
in everyone and to everything." Now this divine will spirituality that we're in
is for the benefit of everybody else. We're not in it for our own
growth in holiness. We leave that to the Lord
and we look after our neighbors. I want to extend myself to
in everyone and to everything. From the first to the last thought,
from the first to the last word, from the first to the last
action, the first to the last step, as it were done,
are done and will be done.
"I want to seal everything with your will," she said,
"so that you may receive from everything the glory of your sanctity,
of your love and of your power, and so that all
that is human may be covered, hidden, and marked
by your will." Now notice covered by the divine will.
We can't change past events into divine will that weren't divine will,
so that all that is human may remain covered, hidden, and marked in the divine
will. May nothing, nothing human remain in which
you do not receive the divine glory, but we're trying to cover them
so that when the human race gathers enough momentum
to really return to the divine will in this other
launch that must actually happen, then
all the rest of the human race benefits as well.
May nothing, nothing human remain in which you do not receive divine glory.
Now, while I was doing this and other things,
my sweet Jesus came all festive accompanied by innumerable
numbers of the blessed. Then he said, "The whole of creation says to me, 'My glory,
my glory,' and all the saints responded, 'Behold, O Lord,
we give you divine glory for everything.'" I could hear an echo from all sides
saying for everything we give you love and glory.
Now, but it's also in the divine will that's got to start that chorus.
The faithfulness needs to come up from the the earth for
righteousness to come down from heaven. That's Sam,
I think it's 86, so Jesus added, "Blessed are you,
and all generations will call you blessed." Isn't that absolutely amazing?
Jesus says to Louisa, what blessed mother said about herself,
that she was so privileged, blessed mother was so privileged,
and all the grace is given to her, and the privileges given to her,
and the mission given to her as well, that all generations would call her
blessed. Now, it will be generations in the future
who will call Louisa, blessed, because we're only at the beginning of this
and very few people as yet have really taken this up.
So, I want to give you Luke 1.48, because those words are taken from Luke 1.48.
"My arm," Jesus said, "will make works of power in you."
Now, "my arm" means the power of God, John 12.38.
"You will be the divine reflection, and filling the whole earth you will make me
receive from all generations that glory which they deny me."
So, it's the beginning of the healing of the human race.
Jesus did everything for us, blessed mother cooperated with everything that
Jesus did, and she is the core of Demetrix,
but we now must actually put our drop of water into the wine of their love.
It's now time for us to pick up the life that was given to us.
That's like saying, the parents have done everything for the children.
It's time now that the children pick up the challenge of life
and go ahead, go forward.
On hearing this, Louisa said she remained confused and annihilated,
and annihilated, I think she means really humiliated.
And I did not want to write, and he caressing me said, "No, no, you will do it.
I want it." You see the fiat there?
There's the pronounced, it's pronounced. If he wants it, it will happen.
It's as simple as that.
What I said will serve for the honor of my will.
I myself wanted to pay the first homage,
which befits the sanctity of my will even more.
I said nothing to prepare, compared to what I could say.
So, Jesus himself is the one who lived the divine, excuse me.
Jesus himself is the one who lived the divine will in all.
It's fullness because he was God and man.
Blessed mother was the next one who lived divine will in all.
It's fullness as a human being.
And now Jesus says he's going to lift Louisa into this extraordinary position,
and she will be the first of all those who were born with original sin
to enter into this great privilege.
We'll stop there for the moment.